hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 1
episode 2 the kingsroad yeah this is a
new video series we're trying here new
rockstars requested by the viewers after
breaking down season 6 and 7 with you
guys to go back and re-watch from the
beginning pointing out interesting
details and connections and episodes
that you might have missed the first
time around and you guys seem to like my
breakdown to the pilot episode so let's
just keep moving forward
episode 2 quick reminder this is the
episode Arya and Joffrey fight as they
head south on the Kings Road resulting
in Ned having to kill Sansa's dire wolf
lady as well as Brandt's assassination
attempt and awakening from his coma and
Daenerys learning to seduce Khal Drogo
her way oh yeah this show used to cram a
lot of plot into one episode and sex by
the way this episode also gives us maybe
the most satisfying moment of the season
of course it's hard to enjoy this moment
for too long because the Hound follows
it with this ominous telltale worthy
line the prince will remember that
little Lord
of course Joffrey will pay back Tyrion
for this tenfold over the coming seasons
okay I realize that some of you may be
watching these videos while you're
watching the series for the first time
without knowing future events by the way
welcome to the world out from under your
rock but if you want to keep fresh eyes
and skip any foreshadowing that I do you
can skip to this time alright good
they're gone for the rest of season
Watchers on the wall let's dive deep
into the subtle moments that connect to
echo or foreshadow future events in our
segment in hindsight this scene with the
Lannisters discussing brans health over
breakfast has a few interesting
exchanges even if the boy lives should
be a a grotesque give me good
clean death any day
speaking for the grotesques I'd have to
disagree death is so final as life life
is full of possibilities on one level
Tyrion is defending his own existence to
his brother he was born to use Jamie's
words here a grotesque
but he prefers that life to no
life at all but also yeah this is a
hugely ironic thing for Jamie to say
given his future as a grotesque
but in many ways losing his hand will be
his characters journey opening his life
to be full of possibility and then the
scene ends this way my dear brother out
of time she like we wonder whose side
you're on
my dear brother you wound me you know
how much I love my family
in hindsight this exchange for shadows
both Jamie and Tyrians future conflict
on opposite sides of the war between
Cersei and Dany in season seven but also
Tyrians defense to Catelyn in the book
that he couldn't possibly have one
little fingers dagger from him in a bed
against his brother during the tourney
because quote I never bet against my
family this episode again for shadows
Jaime's amputation when he bids Jon
adieu notice the camera gives us his
tight close-up of his hand the same hand
that gets chopped off Jaime also says
this to John grateful good strong men
like you protecting us now Jamie's being
sarcastic here but Season seven later
we'll show him genuinely expressing
gratitude for John's struggles
protecting the realm and heading north
to join him in that struggle okay let's
move into this goodbye scene between
Arya and Jon now to date this is the
only scene in this series of Game of
Thrones with these two characters
together so it's an interesting that
we're all so desperate for a reunion
between them now of course Ari and Jon
are both stark outsiders who become key
protagonists in the series but I think
it really comes down to Jon giving her
needle in this moment one character
giving another a sword is usually a
defining character moment and notice
Jon's line here first listen sticking
with the pointy end these words actually
come back next episode when Ned decides
to let Arya train with needles the
pointy end is actually the title of
episode 8 the season so last video I
pointed out how interesting it was that
Game of Thrones already started laying
the seeds of the mystery of Jon's true
mother early and a stark this episode
goes even deeper into it first there are
these final words between Ned and Jon
you wanna stop
my name behind my blood is my mother
alive does she know about me where I am
where I'm going
she can't the next time we see each
other who talked about you mother notice
the pain that actor Sean Bean conveys
here apparently the actor was told the
actual truth that Ned was hiding the
tragic reality that John's mother is
Ned's sister Lyanna who died in his arms
spinning off the noise actually said
that Georgia or Martin gave them the
rights to adapt the books into an HBO
series only after they answered the
question who is Jon Snow's mother
so assuming they got that answer right
it's possible that they passed this
secret subtext along to Sean Bean which
is why he's able to play these scenes so
suspiciously also another little
connection here I like how later in
season six a character named after Ned's
sister Lyanna Mormont echoes Ned's words
here we know no king but a king in the
North whose name is stark I don't care
if he's a busted that stops blood runs
through his veins now in the following
scene Sean Bean again does a remarkable
job showing that stirred secret when
discussing this lie with Robert yours
was Elena know told it was Meryl your
bastards mother while at that's it must
have been a rare wench to make Lord
Eddard Stark forget his honor you never
told me what she looked like
no will I and then a little after this
notice Ned's reaction when Robert rants
about the Targaryen well her father did
to your family that was unspeakable what
Rhaegar Targaryen did to your sister the
woman I loved
I'll kill every Targaryen I get my hands
off Ned knows that Rhaegar and his
sister actually loved each other and the
Targaryen Ned is most concerned about
protecting from Robert is actually
Rhaegar and Lyanna striae on Targaryen
John now later there's this interesting
scene between John and Tyrion my father
was the hand of the King for 20 years
until your brother killed that King yes
until my brother killed him life is full
of these little ironies Tyrion is right
to point out the irony here Jon's
judgment of Jaime for breaking his vows
as a knight to protect the king well
later look pretty hypocritical when Jon
tries to break his vows to abandon the
Nights Watch I'm moving on of course the
Valyrian steel cat's paw dagger used in
brans attempted murder in hindsight
becomes a major piece of evidence in
later episodes and in the Reese
season is kind of a smoking gun that
brand uses to convict little finger and
then notice the sexplanations I'm sorry
the Dothraki handmaid gives Daenerys
here no Khaleesi you must look in his
eyes always love comes in at the eyes
yeah Danny will remember this Cosmo sex
tip when she makes love with John later
notice how in the season finale she
never breaks eye contact with her nephew
yeah you should feel gross about it and
later during the debate between Ned
Robert and Cersei over what to do about
the kids there was an interesting little
moment when Sansa is called in as a
witness where's your other daughter Ned
in bed asleep
do you know Sansa come here darling
Ned looks totally caught off guard here
Cersei has already begun to manipulate
his eldest daughter behind his back and
this manipulation is confirmed by
Circe's satisfied smile when the stark
girls turn on each other she's in and
the Starks are beginning to unravel and
all of this is setting up when Cersei
will exploit Sansa during Ned's
conviction later this season and in the
fealty letter she makes Sansa send Rob
by the way that letter also comes back
to haunt son since season seven becoming
a source of conflict between her and
Arya I notice that Arya reacts here this
is essentially a more childish version
of the game of faces Arya recently put
Sansa through and then when Ned declares
that he not Ilyn Payne the Royal
executioner will put down sonses dire
wolf lady he snaps this line at Cersei
she must be doing do it myself
this is some trick the wolf is of the
north she deserves better than a butcher
and a camera cuts to Joffrey
foreshadowing how Ned will end the
season on this kids butcher's block Ned
insisting on executing the direwolf
himself is a callback to his philosophy
on justice that he explained to bran
last episode the man who passes the
sentence should swing the sword in this
case the sentence was technically passed
by Robert the king but since the king
left the room that job has fallen to the
hand of the king Ned Ned believes that
he should carry out the Kings justice
not the executioner because that's the
way it's done in the north and on an
emotional level he probably feels like
he passed the sentence he was one
responsible for bringing his daughters
and their wolves into this whole
situation now I'll talk about this
ending late
but first I want to go through and point
out all the other ways this episode
paralleled past moments in our segment
callbacks okay so when Cersei talks with
Catelyn at Brandt's bedside she talks
about how Robert punched the walls when
their firstborn died all the things men
do to show you how much they care
now Cersei is referring to her husband
Robert but she's using the words of the
brother she's cheating on Robert with
the things I do for love and later in
the scene Cersei tells Kat that she
never visited that baby's body in the
crypts and it's kind of a callback to
her annoyance that Robert visited
Leanna's grave in the crypts of
Winterfell last episode again we're
seeing how Cersei is not a character
who's reverent or superstitious when it
comes to mortality once people die she
doesn't pay a respects she just moves on
then before summer saves brand from the
assassin Catelyn initially wanted Rob to
silence all howling direwolves she
wanted them gone but then she becomes
grateful in allowed summer to stay on
brans bed and if you think about it this
is parallel to Kaitlyn's attitude for
Jon this episode earlier when he said a
brand's bedside to tell him goodbye she
said this to geez Catelyn wanted to
throw out Jon like a dog but now her
gratitude his summer begins to make up
for this coldness to Jon her heart for
these outside dogs is beginning to warm
there's actually something interesting
about the shot that I want to come back
to later but I want to talk more about
this scene between Cersei and Catelyn
it's for me one of the most interesting
moments this episode for one it was Lena
Headey Zhou dition scene that got her
the part of Cersei but also this scene
was purely a creation for the show this
conversation doesn't happen in the book
a Game of Thrones
let's actually go through all the ways
this episode altered things from the
source material in our segment well in
the books okay yeah so in the scenes
Cersei reveals to Catelyn that she and
Robert had a son with dark hair who died
from fever shortly after birth and
Cersei isn't lying to Catelyn here later
in episode 5 a private conversation with
her and Robert confirms this well in the
books this isn't the case at all Cersei
does reveal later that she conceived a
child with Robert but she aborted it out
of spite for him
I know Yanks the only children in the
books that Cersei brought to term where
Joffrey Marcel and Tom and Jaime's kids
I think that show changes because
starting a book for a piece for crows
actually begin to get chapters from
sources point of view which really help
us
the thighs was Circe's a character and
Sears less of a true villain and more is
this more of morally complex character
now on the show meanwhile we can't read
Circe's thoughts so in order to keep
Cersei as a character we love to hate
and not as a character who we hate and
hate to watch they need to keep us on
the hook with these sympathetic moments
they're also a few smaller changes like
in the books Catelyn actually tells some
of the words thank you for saving bran
and the events at the end of the
crossroads actually take place at castle
Derry where Renly Baratheon and
Barristan Selmy actually arrived with
Ilyn Payne rather than waiting for
Robert and Ned down in King's Landing in
episode 3 also the book is as more
historical context for the river Ari and
Joffrey fight next to this is right
around Ruby Ford at the Trident the
place where Robert crushed Rhaegar
Targaryen in battle Robert's Warhammer
famously smashed the rubies out of
Rhaegar his breastplate and scattered
them into the water arya and the
butcher's boy are actually trying to
find these rubies and since arya
humiliated Joffrey at the same location
his father humiliated Rhaegar it makes
even more sense why Robert would be so
pissed at him you let that little girl
disarm you now there's one more big
change from the books but before I get
to it I wanted to give a special thanks
to our sponsor Skillshare who helped us
make this video Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators with
more than 17,000 classes on pretty much
anything like Adobe Premiere and After
Effects which we used to make these
videos as a writer myself was into
analyzing this story and characters of
Game of Thrones
I love storytelling fundamentals
character conflict context and crafts
taught by Daniel Jose older the first
300 people to click on the promo link in
the description will receive a two-month
free trial to Skillshare and all of its
resources it's as low as ten dollars a
month after that to continue learning if
you enjoy it or cancel it if you don't
there's no risk there's even a mobile
app on Android and iPhone that allows
you to tap into classes when you're
offline just check out skl sh / new
rockstar so click on the link in the
description to get started okay the
final big adaptation from the book is
this closing shot when bran wakes up
from his coma
well in the books we experience Brants
coma through his own two eyes or in this
case three eyes as he hears the voice of
the three-eyed crow
yes in the books it's Crowe not
three-eyed Raven brand soars high over
Westeros looking down on his father and
sisters near the Trident and seeing
beyond the wall and what he sees makes
him cry
he knows officially that winter is
coming so when he wakes up a name for
his direwolf finally comes to him as he
says his name is
the show held off on these trippy
visions probably assuming in that
episode - it's a little too early to
throw the fantastical three-eyed Raven
elements to the viewers instead giving
us a simpler dream sequence later in the
season now let's move on to some of the
more notable music choices this episode
in our segment
this episode features the first known
instance of Ramin Djawadi z-- House
Stark theme which ironically plays
during a scene with two characters who
currently feel the least in common with
a smart family John and Aria these first
two episodes definitely make it seem
like Ned and Catelyn are gonna be the
shows stark protagonists but this music
cue hints that these two characters are
actually going to be carrying the torch
for the family in the long run of the
series
now how stark theme comes back two more
key moments this episode burst when John
says goodbye to bran
[Music]
and later when Catelyn says goodbye to
her son
[Music]
now notice this arts-and-crafts thingy
that Catelyn sweetly made for brand out
of garbage if you look closely zooming
and enhancing on this there are seven
figures in this God's eye a
seven-pointed star composed of these
seven new gods actually throughout the
episode you can see Catelyn gradually
assembling the pieces of this let's dive
in and examine some of the other
miscible visual details in this episode
in our segment zooming in hands
okay so early in the episode when Tyrion
delivers the news to his siblings that
bran might pull through notices subtle
look he gives them checking in on their
reactions maester says the boy may live
despite being hungover and having just
woken up in a dog kennel tyrion still
has enough wits about him to one know
that brands accident was probably caused
by his incestuous siblings and to
slightly gauge their poker faces then
with Daenerys this episode notice how
both times she has sex with Khal Drogo
her eyeline clings to her three dragon
eggs she's literally keeping her eyes on
the prize in fact the only reason Dany
initially talks to the hand maid who
teaches her these sexy tips is because
that one was babbling on about dragons
hatching out of a moon egg Dany was just
like who tell me more about them dragons
in that moon egg so really this
struggled to take control of her sexual
relationship with Drogo is framed as a
step toward her end goal this season to
become the mother of dragons
okay next coming back to the shot that I
mentioned before notice is the framing
when Catelyn coldly tells Jon to leave
her husband Ned is cleverly positioned
in the background between them so that
Catelyn is almost directing this rage at
Ned this is after all what catlins anger
is all about she's actually mad at Ned
for bringing this bastard into the
family but since she really can't take
out that anger on her noble Lord husband
Jon becomes a scapegoat
speaking of scapegoats let's move on to
the deeper meaning this episode so this
episode is titled the kingsroad and
actually writer on the show Bryan cogman
initially suggested Roberts line a
direwolf is no pet as the episodes title
but bending up hated the title so much
that he told him that if he ever died
prematurely to never name any Game of
Thrones episode a direwolf is no patent
in either case this episode's deeper
meaning hinges on the heartbreaking
execution of Lady sonses dire wolf and
let's not forget the butcher's boy who
was
cruelly run down by the hound these
characters are archetypal scapegoats
escape goats are innocents who suffer
for the crimes and sins of others in
literature history of pop culture
scapegoats take on unfair punishment so
that a corrupt society can process an
injustice and move on but and doing so
proves itself to be even more unjust and
we can look at the title the kingsroad
as kind of a play on words what does it
cost these characters to take the Kings
Road to enter the high-stake world of
rulers for Ned Stark choosing the path
to join the king in this political game
has already left him with blood on his
hands he has brought pain to his wife
their daughters their direwolf's and
himself by taking the Kings Road and as
we'll find over and over throughout the
series lady and the butcher's boy won't
be the only victims of this decision
thousands of innocents will be sentenced
to death to pay for the petty squabbles
of these highborn lords and ladies
because on Game of Thrones when you take
the Kings Road the little guy pays the
toll did this altered scene with Cersei
changed the way you see your character
and who would you say is the most at
fault for lady's death
Cersei Joffrey Ned Sansa Arya Roberts or
in I'm area yeah way to throw your
fellow dire wolf under the bus comment
down below and tweet me your thoughts
directly at EI vos or follow new
rockstars on twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our videos and yeah keep
those thoughts coming on these classic
episode re-watch videos in general like
this is still an experimental thing
we're busy covering lots of stuff on
this channel so we'll get to these when
we can but it'll really depend on what
you guys want to see and you can help us
want to make more of these videos by
liking and sharing this video and
subscribing to new rockstars for more
Game of Thrones content as we wait for
this long night to end and season 8 to
start you can also help this channel be
more flexible in general by contributing
to us on patreon big thanks to all of
our current donors especially Kenny
Smith alright thanks for watching bye